l'allemagne est la religion des masques
vous l'avez dit c'est rare de voir des
gens sans masque pour autant est ce
qu'il ya et ce qu'est la police est ce
qu ont contrôlé ce qu'on verbalise en
france on est très fiers ministre de
l'intérieur est très fier de dire qu'il
a fait un pas que tant de français ont
été verbalisés voilà ça fait partie de
notre notre folklore national ça n'est
pas le cas en allemagne
non on n'en parle pas même dans les
journaux locaux il ya aucune histoire de
personnes testées de personnes mais
savait l'allemagne est un pays où il ya
plus de contrôle social qu'il n'ya de
deux contrôles policiers
c'est valable pour les radars automobile
comme pour le reste c'est à dire c'est
votre voisin le monsieur qui est à côté
de vous dans le magasin etc qui va vous
dire qu' il faudrait matin masques et 7
cette parole est presque une obligation
parce qu'elle est pris sur le ton de la
jonction
mais il n'y a pas de menace si rien du
tout on vous dit simplement monsieur
supporters donc voilà l'allemagne est un
pays de contrôle social et pas du tout
fier d'être de contrôle policier
il existe quand même des radars il
existe quand même des gens qui sont
flashés dans mois creux vite mais voilà
il faut pas croire que les allemands
contrairement à ce qu'on pense sont très
disciplinés discipline discipline ils
ont un contrôle social c'est à dire que
on regarde ce que fait l'autre et on est
si les directives comme la chancelière
l'a dit de se confiner de ne pas avoir
trop de contacts sociaux de ne pas avoir
de réunion de famille de plus de deux
familles avec 10 personnes au maximum
si vous voulez c'est c'est ce que dit la
chancelière c'est ce que je dis là je me
porte sur ceux de la loi c'est la
directive
c'est ce que dit la directive donc on
obéit
on doit venir ça parce que parce que
votre voisin peut vous dire mais dis
donc machin tu restes tu fais que te pas
ce qui est la directive
de l'état
[Musique]